c'est en inde qu'il se vend le plus de
livres au monde
vous me direz c'est normal avec une
population d'1 milliard 300 millions
d'habitants
sauf que c'est aussi en inde qu'on lit
le plus longtemps en moyenne 10 heures
par semaine c'est deux fois plus que les
canadiens les indiens sont tout
simplement les champions de monde de la
lecture
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque dimanche matin dans le vieux
delhi c'est le rendez vous des
passionnés de livres d'occasion
les vendeurs s'installe directement sur
le trottoir sur une distance d'un
kilomètre
les collectionneurs sont les premiers
arrivés comme vikash gupta qui vient là
depuis dix ans
en inde il ya souvent des balances chez
les marchands de livres d'occasion car
ici on les vend qui loue comme les
fruits et légumes entre 1 et 4 dollars
le kilo les meilleures journées
ramesh hodja en vend une tonne michel
d'africa banking classique
des palissades à étudie en littérature
anglaise et possède déjà 1000 livres
collectés uniquement le livre indien qui
s'est le mieux vendu ces dernières
années c'est one night at the call
center une histoire d'amour vendu à un
million d'exemplaires à travers les
livres les deux tiers d'indiens qui
savent lire peuvent rêver voyager à en
prenant nos yeux plein des nouveaux
managers kashyap 78 ans se prépare à
parcourir le sri lanka et l'espagne mais
pas sur place dans sa tête c'est bien
moins cher et on se déplace bien plus
vite le marché de l'imprimé est encore
en pleine forme en inde
contrairement à chez nous le salon du
livre de calcutta est par exemple plus
important du monde après celui de
francfort
il s'est vendu pour près de 5 millions
de dollars de bouquins à la dernière
édition
la presse indienne ne connaît pas non
plus la crise les journaux papiers sont
encore très populaires et il sent publie
pas moins de 2000 édition chaque jour
encore un record mondial
[Musique]